How did the seals deal with fatigue,
soreness and beat down and the beat down of buds and SQT without getting
injured?
Well you just get used to it.
And,
and again,
you know,
I say this all the time buds and the SQT,
which is the kind of the initial training after you had done with buds,
which is the basic underwater demolition seal training.
That's a short part of your career.
I mean it's literally a fraction of your career means nothing.
Um,
but just like any working out you get used to it.
And if it's like when you work out,
when you,
if you haven't worked out for a long time or someone that's someone that just
starts working out from nowhere,
never worked out before,
they're going to be sore as hell when they first work out.
I just had this happen to me cause I got,
I want,
I went on the road,
I went on a road trip multiple back to back road trips and I went overseas,
came back when I came back I got sick.
So I was for like three weeks,
I hadn't squatted heavy at all.
I had nobody at all I did was bodyweight squats,
you know,
pistols,
just lunges.
That's how I work my legs.
There's just no way.
So you just do what you can do a hotel room in some strange part of Europe.
And when I came back,
I was all happy and I got on that squad.
Once I,
he won,
then I was sick.
And then once I got done being sick,
I finally felt good and I got back on that squat rack and man,
my legs were destroyed for four or five days.
I'm talking,
you know,
having a hard time sitting down and having a hard time standing up.
It was gnarly.
And,
but,
but that's just because my body just,
it just wasn't,
he lost that element.
So of course if you just started working out and you're walking around sore all
the time,
that's,
that's because you got to get used to it.
Um,
and in buds you do get injured just because it's massively repetition.
You know,
there was a guy that we had that was a trainer,
an athletic trainer for a professional sports team.
And
when he was there,
there's this great example,
there's something called Patella for moral syndrome,
which is when your Patella,
because of the way you're running,
it rubs on your,
your femur.
And it becomes problematic.
And he said in like a whole season in the NFL or he would see maybe one of those
injuries may be too,
and you'll have to figure out what it is.
And when he was working in buds,
he would literally see 30 of those a week.
So you just get to see,
I mean there's more people,
there's 10 times the people,
but it still was massive amount of injuries.
And it's the same thing in the seal teams and the seal teams.
It's your shoulders,
it's your back,
it's your knees,
it's your ankles,
you get abused.
And it's,
it's,
it's not the working out that does it to you.
It's not working out.
It's carrying a guy on your shoulder,
over the rocky terrain,
out in the desert and tripping on ankle.
That's what you get hurt.
It's jumping over off of a wall and you land on a cinderblock that breaks and
you bro,
you know,
it's,
that's the kind of stuff.
But working out doesn't really do it to you.
I actually,
one of the things when,
when I was a tasking to commander,
we were going through land warfare training and I would work out every day and I
would roll with guys like teach them some Jujitsu and enroll with them and I
would,
you know,
guys are,
cause you know,
we're working hard during the day or during the night.
And I was kind of making fun of some guys that were taking Motrin and I was
like,
you don't need that.
You're weak.
And stuff like that.
And sure enough,
right after we got done,
I got something called Bursitis in my elbow because in land warfare,
you're constantly getting down to the desert,
you're crawling,
you're,
and then I was in Jujitsu Jitsu on the Mat and I did bang it a couple times and
sure enough,
my elbow swelled up and I had to take Motrin.
Yeah,
don't,
uh,
don't open your mouth Jocko.
Just keep it to yourself.
Um,
so you know,
and again,
I was,
I was hammering guys but in a joking manner and so they hammered me right back
when I had the Motrin pills to try and heal that up.
Um,
but it is,
like I said,
it's the,
it's the injuries come from not from working out.
In fact,
I always think that the working out prevents the injuries.
You know,
that I think that's true with everything.
I think that's true with Jujitsu.
I think that's true with life.
You,
you,
you work out,
you're strong.
You're joints are strong,
your muscle densities better.
Your,
I mean,
just just work out because it'll prevent injuries more than,
more than I don't worry about,
I look at working out,
not as injury is going to happen.
I look at working out as injury prevention.
And the last thing is you shouldn't need to like completely crush yourself every
day in your workouts.
I mean,
you shouldn't be going to a point that you have massive muscle soreness over
your whole body or over even body parts.
You don't need to do that.
Uh,
you know,
do you want to push yourself?
Yeah.
You want to push yourself,
but you want to speak so sore that you aid like can't perform your job.
Uh,
and also I like,
you know,
active rest,
I hardly ever just do nothing.
Occasionally I will occasionally I'll just,
man,
I'm broke down and just eat steak and just chill.
But uh,
but I like to do the active rest,
you know,
I like to do some kind of jogs,
swam,
surf,
whatever.
And you know,
actually Jujitsu,
like if I have a sore back,
I love getting on the Mat.
It just loosens everything up.
Feels so good.
But that's only at a certain level.
Yeah.
Cause when you're a white belt or a blue belts or ho purple belts,
Ben,
that Bri and it's just a battle.
You're,
you're getting off the mat sore.
I don't get off the mat source when she did too.
Seldom seldom do I get off the mat.
Like,
man,
I'm tired.
I mean,
we trained today.
I'm not,
that was a no factor.
You know what I mean?
It was just,
Oh yeah,
we trained the pill.
If you get into the takedown elements though,
the,
that will,
even if you got to be hard on your back,
but even the takedown elements,
you know,
if you're just going to do pure takedowns yet,
but I'm going to take down,
it's going to last how long and if your sore,
pull guard and work on something else.
So that's it in the bottom line is you work out,
you do so many of these workouts,
you'll get used to it,
you'll get in the zone and then you won't be so sore all the time.
Yeah.
That as an advocate of rest,
I uh,
that's important.
That part where you're like,
don't beat your doubt yourself.
Done.
Cause the exercise that technically freely split hairs here,
the exercise doesn't make you stronger.
The recovery from the exercise is when you get stronger.
So yeah,
that says a part of the whole system that makes you strong.
But when you recover from that exercise,
that's when you're stronger.
I'll give you them.
So yeah.
But the workout itself is what induces the recovery,
so.
Sure.
Yeah.
So there you go.
Um,
you,
well I guess so it's all kinds of different philosophies,
right?
Different approaches.
Like you,
you prefer the active arrest,
um,
and not going hard every day.
Some people they prefer go hard every day,
but then they'll have a straight up to three days off completely,
you know?
Um,
but yeah,
the recovery from the exercise,
that's,
that's the ticket right there.
And when I say go hard,
I mean like the muscular,
you know,
destroy,
like if you can do squats until you can't walk,
you can't do that all the time and you don't need to write,
you need to initiate the growth.
You don't need to destroy them and,
and you can do you,
you know,
you can put with them with the metabolic conditioning,
you can really can destroy herself a lot more often.
And if you're doing it right,
you shouldn't really be getting muscularly sore from your metabolic condition if
you're doing it right.
But then again,
he's a,
isn't that really a spectrum as well?
It is a spectrum.
Con can be like a heavier it can I quicker with.
That's the,
that's the beauty of working on,
that's why you should never get bored with working out.
She can change it up.